este problema dice suma 5x cuadrada más
8 x 3 con 2 x cuadrada menos 7 x + 13 x
o sea tenemos que sumar 2 polinomios y
de hecho este segundo polinomio que nos
dan se puede simplificar así luego luego
porque tiene dos términos similares no
es el término x cuadrada porque no hay
ningún otro x cuadrada sino me refiero a
estos dos a estos dos que ambos tienen x
elevado a la una entonces vamos a
simplificar esto cuánto nos quedaría
pues tenemos 13 x y a eso tenemos que
restarle 7 x si tenemos 13 cosas y nos
quitan 7 entonces nos quedan 6 verdad
entonces serían
entonces podemos simplificar estos dos
suman 2 a 6x y el otro se quedaría igual
déjame ponerlo como 2 x al cuadrado más
6x muy bien entonces esta es la forma
simplificada de este segundo polinomio
que nos dan y lo que queremos es sumar
este polinomio al primero va lo que
vamos a hacer es escribir este este
primer polinomio aquí abajo en color
morado y después vamos a sumar hacia
abajo entonces vamos a escribirlo
cuidadosamente para que los términos
similares queden en la misma columna de
este modo hay que poner el 5 x al
cuadrado aquí 5 x al cuadrado más el 8 x
aquí debajo de este 6 x más 8 x ive el
de arriba no tiene término constante no
tiene ningún término con x a la 0
entonces simplemente este menos 3 lo voy
a poner de este lado menos 3 muy bien ya
que tenemos los polinomios alineados
podemos sumar los podemos sumar los aquí
de arriba para abajo entonces vamos a
ver qué nos queda déjame ponerlo con
este color rojo y entonces vamos a ver
si tenemos 5x cuadrada
le sumamos 2x cuadrada entonces
obtenemos 7 x al cuadrado 5 12 7 luego
si tenemos 6x y le sumamos 8x obtenemos
14 x osea si tú tienes 6x y yo te doy 8x
obtenemos 14 x obtienes 14 x en total y
finalmente este menos 3 no hay que
sumarlo con nada entonces simplemente
nos queda menos 3 vale menos 3 entonces
ya realizamos la suma de estos dos
polinomios y nos quedó 7 x cuadrada más
14 x menos 3